drame dans la course à la voile la baule
dakar daniel gilard le skipper de jet
services tombent à la mer les chances de
le retrouver vivant sont extrêmement
faibles
le dow jones en accordéon les promesses
de reggane de s'attaquer au déficit
budgétaire n'ont pas convaincu la bourse
de new york à paris l'indicateur perd 0
46%
8 jouera pas le coup d'état le nouvel
homme fort du burkina faso blaise
campaoré défini ses objectifs il faut
revenir aux engagements du début de la
révolution 2000 francs par mois et une
protection sociale garantie aux plus
défavorisés
le dispositif fait partie d'un plan
d'action du gouvernement contre la
pauvreté et la précarité
une journée supplémentaire de détention
pour marcel carton marcel fontaine jean
paul kauffmann jean louis normandin
d'antenne 2 et roger au les otages
français au liban n'ont toujours pas été
libérés
lino ventura terrassé par une crise
cardiaque à 68 ans est sans doute le
plus pudique et le plus secret de nos
grands comédiens qui s'était ainsi hier
soir
lino ventura était un personnage dont il
ne fallait attendre ni démagogie ni
confidence il faisait son métier avec
talent c'est tout avant d'évoquer sa vie
et sa carrière je vous propose d'écouter
quelques réactions sur un plateau de
tournage
hervé brusini vous êtes avec nous en
direct d'epinay et henry henry malgré
tout le cinéma continue ici à epinay sur
seine claude sautet son équipe réalisent
leur dernier film quelques jours avec
moi je peux vous dire que ce soir cette
équipe dans toute sa diversité chef
opérateur maquilleuse éclairagiste
producteurs et bien tout le monde pense
tout le monde a une pensée pour lino
ventura et sa famille que claude sautet
vous allez travailler à deux reprises
avec lino ventura voilà ma main un
beaucoup plus leur président que je
connais comme cet assistant je connais à
l'aide beaucoup des trois rôles on
petit rôle ce qui était pour lui
dérisoires et pas non plus conclut et
c'est après que notre aventure écoutez
je vous propose henry de revenir tout à
l'heure ici sur ce plateau et nous
parlerons plus en détails de cette
rencontre entre claude sautet et lino
ventura ainsi qu'avec un ingénieur du
son qui a travaillé plusieurs reprises
avec lui aujourd'hui devant domicile du
comédien à saint-cloud l'émotion se
joignait à la tristesse et au respect
surtout commentaires de yoba grégoire
saint cloud un pavillon parmi tant
d'autres un jardin paisible une journée
d'automne banale si ce n'est ces allers
venues inhabituel démarche présente dos
courbé ce sont les proches les amis de
vino ventura
pour les autres la surprise les
souvenirs tanger ont cassé la bouteille
et que ça va bien toi un mois de
décembre plus d'une quinzaine d'années
et bien manger façon italienne bien sûr
aussi c'est lui même qui les avaient
préparés et joue pas avec ducati
ce passé la journée avec lui depuis dix
ans le matin jusqu'à issue fatale
une journée très belle ensoleillé
d'ailleurs tout le monde était heureux
et content nous avions rendez vous à 5h
à saint chéron dans l'essonne nous
sommes partis ensemble h environ
il conduisait d'ailleurs ma voiture et
est en pleine forme et nous avons nous
sommes restés une seconde partie ce soir
vers 6 heures et on est rentré chez lui
pour continuer c'est arrivé brutalement
comme un accident en fait puisque il
avait elle paraît les dominos pour faire
la fameuse partie le matin après donc
personne ne pensait
là rien d'un seul coup tout le monde a
fait le maximum on peut pas vraiment
presque plus que le maximum mais quand
c'est l'heure c'est l'heure depuis hier
soir les témoignages se succèdent il
faut dire que lino ventura avait le
culte de l'amitié des comédiens à la
classe politique
tout le monde aujourd'hui a perdu un ami
précieux et chaleureux le dur à cuire au
coeur tendre comme le surnommaient
certains de ses proches était un homme
solide et très sympathique il n'y avait
pas une grande différence entre ce
qu'ils étaient dans la vie et ce qui la
représentation qu'ils avaient à l'écran
le public s'y est pas trompé je vais
aussi le public aimait tant lino c'est
parce qu'il savait très bien que le bea
qui était sur l'écran et éleva qui était
dans la vie je savais très bien qu'ils
s'étaient pas un acteur de composition
qui faisait semblant d'être courageux
qui laisse en blanc d'avoir le coeur tu
fais semblant d'aller au secours des
autres quand il a incarné jean valjean
dans les misérables
il est jean valjean c'était bon l'acteur
maintenant professionnels absolument
extraordinaire parce qu'ils exigent
parce que modestes bars câble parce que
une présence formidable énormément de
générosité des bontés et peu à peu une
capote et plus ils et elles vivaient ces
personnages du weekly des vérités
déjeuner ensemble
c'était quelque chose d'important et
c'est lui qui faisait la cuisine en la
plupart des cas et c'est lui qui nous
servait je veux dire c'est oui ce geste
là alors ça c'est tout teinté lino cette
générosité du coeur c'est minos était un
exemple pour nous il était exemplaire
c'était un homme du peuple le plus beau
sens du mot très généreux on dit qu'il
était très pudique très petit très petit
oui il ya des choses qui refusait de
faire parce que il voulait pas trop se
livrer il était secret aussi il était
discret vous voyez à quel point il n'a
pas aimé la publicité dans sa vie il a
toujours été un petit peu farouches un
peu sauvage
il s'est beaucoup consacrée à sa famille
à cette oeuvre qui est très importante
parmi les autres artistes et je veux
qu'on continue son oeuvre
parce que lorsque lui à fond des
perce-neige il était tellement pudique
il était tellement discret que nous on
avait honte aussi de se mettre en avant
mais maintenant qu'il est mort moi je
continuerai personnellement mais alors
d'une façon non discrète à m'occuper de
personnages mais vous l'avez entendu
tout à l'heure dans la bouche de
françoise fabian au sommet de sa gloire
lino ventura toujours refusé la
publicité le star system pour mieux se
consacrer à l'association personnage une
association qu'il avait d'ailleurs créé
lui-même pour venir en aide à l'enfance
handicapée
ce drame il le connaissait bien car
l'une de ses trois filles étaient
paralysés c'est pour faire sourire les
enfants handicapés pour les aider que le
gros bras des années 60 était devenu un
homme de coeur à sèvres la maison
personnages restent silencieuses ici on
est trop abattu par la nouvelle aucun
commentaire juste le chagrin il ne
ventura et sa femme avaient fondé
personnel en 66 aussi ont une fille pas
comme les autres handicapé mental
aujourd'hui grâce à eux l'association
parraine 22 foyers en france
réinsertion des handicapés et surtout
pouvoir leur offrir un toit lorsque les
parents ne seront plus là en 79 la
maison de sèvres étaient dans un triste
état
écoutez les réactions dans le quartier
al annonce de l'installation des
handicapés mentaux
elles permettent de mesurer la
difficulté du vrai combat de lino
ventura mais ils sont inoffensifs
moi ça me dérange pas
que ça se fasse à mais je pense que
j'aurais pu faire un petit un quartier
moins évité alors quand la générosité la
chaleur humaine venait à sa rencontre
lino ventura cachait mal son émotion
l'a5 wii est heureuse de vous offrir 250
mille francs 25 millions de centimes
pour personnel
je ne suis pas très très habile dans les
discours mais je voudrais vous dire une
seule chose au nom de tous ses enfants
un grand merci
eh oui que d'émotions vous l'avez vu
dans cette image à travers plusieurs
extraits de films je vous propose de
revenir sur la carrière exceptionnelle
de lino ventura sa première apparition
sur les écrans date de 1953 aux côtés de
jean gabin qui deviendra d'ailleurs son
ami ce qui est étonnant chez lino
ventura c'est qu'en dépit de son côté
bourgault et bagarreur il savait
émouvoir le spectateur xtrata qui
peuvent le vrai il est toujours agréable
qu'est-ce qu'on a dû se faire piéger
bâtisseur
non je n'ai pas dit ça mais vous y
pensez
on a payé c'est normal
on va être tout le bleu
sur la vie sur le métier en fait un
vieux cheval
et pas qu'ils ont autre chose à faire
aujourd'hui les flics
alors quoi vous l'avenir j'ai téléphoné
jeudi vient ça pas voulu venir
même quand je serai mort tu me crois pas
j'aime avoir votre caisse
si ça c'est ma pièce qu'est ce qu'on
peut vous servir du vin nom prénom
profession martineau mais je demandais
quand c'est moi qui vous le demande
qu'est ce que voient les frontales
toutes les demandes et toutes les
réponses allant gestion des réponses
vous appelez martineau oui jérôme oui
jérôme charlie mills notaire 43 mozart
de la trouve orange oui vous êtes mariés
oui sans enfant sans enfant pourquoi ça
peut déraper
quelque chose aujourd'hui vous en doutez
sur les plateaux de tournage fumage de
lino ventura était évidemment dans tous
les esprits il faut dire que le comédien
avait tourné plus de 70 films aux côtés
des plus grands réalisateurs parmi eux
claude sautet qui est avec nous en
direct aux côtés d' hervé brusini hervé
tout à fait en rions vient justement de
voir une image de larmes à gauche un
film tourné en 1965
mais la première rencontre entre claude
sautet et lino ventura c'est 1960 ces
classes tout risque est-ce que ça sape a
été une sorte de révolution dans votre
vie claude sautet ou est absolument seul
je croisais de plus 56 et colisée en
l'air avec la scénariste abritant le
projet la tournée il avait tourné un
vrai qu'ils et elles pouvaient lâcher et
moi à l'époque pas tellement envie de
vous étiez assistant
oui il arrive et genre et il m'a appelé
je vous ai très bien entendu j'ai fait
toutes les fins de ce film et il m'a dit
est ce que la journée ou pas s'il sait
bien que vous vous demandez de franchir
le pas oui oui j'suis pas répond quoi
amélie écoute bien j'allais va te donner
je vais devoir me dis alors j'ai rien à
dire lille c'était un point sur les
matins ou non alors évidemment je suis
le chapitre je dis oui et je me suis
fait ses classes touristes et c'est vrai
moi je suis mans tout autre jour je me
fais mes enceintes 6 mai prochain on
peut presque dire que si vous êtes en
train de tourner ici ce soir c'est un
peu grâce à lire sur mon graphe plus et
finalement c'était mieux d'être est dur
et en plus que des sorties n'a pas
marché à l'époque et il narre marché que
deux ambulances et deux ans plus tard et
quand je me suis dit oh et sombre il est
il va être un peu meurtri qui est à la
base du projet je n'ai pas le succès est
meilleur quand il a lu après le bus
classique mais et puis j'aime pas second
cd tellement donné l'un l'autre et ce
fut quand je suis triste que j'ai fait
qu'un jeune a vécu après je voulais en
faire d'autres
mais il a disparu
ah ah bon l'ambiance passion viennent
pour trouver
monsieur le noir vous vous êtes
ingénieur du son vous avez tourné à deux
reprises avec lino ventura et en
papillon sur l'épaule
alors est ce que il était parce qu'on
comparait souvent à un gamin et on
disait que gabin lui aimé qu'on le
registre alors qu'il parlait bas c'était
la même chose pour lino absolument
innovantes aura parlé très très bas
enfin modérément bas mais de toute façon
il était très très consciencieux que
quand il y avait un petit problème il
disait je vais parler plus fort quand
elles prises et il savait très bien et
en plus on pouvait lui même des micro
cravate comme j'ai moi-même et vu ça
c'est très léger embonpoint ça passait
très bien vivre aucun problème qu'est ce
qu'il faisait sur les plateaux c'était
quelqu'un qui était toujours là et il
avait une marrante qu'il est oui il
avait une marotte et peu de gens savent
à part les techniciens qui l'ont
fréquenté ces les mots croisés et dès
qu'il dit un plateau ils allaient
s'insérer dans un coin il faisait des
mots croisés et demandez aux gens qui
l'entouraient de l'aider parce qu'il fut
difficile définition qui comprenait pas
et qui comprenait pas qu'il n'arrivait
pas à trouver il adorait ça voyez henry
le souvenir et là tout à fait présent
les anecdotes sans mousse sont là et je
peux vous dire qu'il ya là aussi
derrière trois jeunes acteurs
il ya vincent lindon daniel auteuil et
puis il ya aussi
qui donc sandrine bonnaire et bien
qu'ils n'ont pas voulu parler parce
qu'ils ont dit que pour eux c'était un
exemple la ville innovante urech il
il voulait mener gérer leur vie d'acteur
comme celle de lino ventura dans la
discrétion
merci antenne 2 rendra hommage à lino
ventura à travers deux soirées
exceptionnelles mardi à 20h30 vous
pourrez voir ou revoir la 7e cible un
film de claude pinoteau demain à 22h25
juste après champs elysées vous pourrez
revoir le grand échiquier de jacques
chancel consacré à lino ventura ce jour
là le 31 mai 79
le comédien avait ému la france entière
en évoquant l' indifférence des hommes
et on parlait aussi de l'indifférence il
y à cet épisode lorsque vous tourniez le
papillon sur l'épaule vous est abattu et
je crois que c'est quelque part vu
tomber alors qu'on ne voit pas du tout
les caméras ne peut pas savoir qu' il ya
cinéma oui c'est un épisode qui m'a qui
m'a beaucoup frappé effectivement sur
l'indifférence des gens parce qu'en plus
et c'est venu comme ça dans ce film
parce que c'était un peu le thème qu'on
a voulu faire transpirer travers ce film
le faire apparaître
je ne sais pas si on est arrivé mais le
fait est qu'à la fin de ce fil
les caméras étaient cachés je me
souviens dans un immeuble en face de la
gare de barcelone ça se déroulait à
barcelone et je sortais de la gare et là
j'étais censé prendre une balle en plein
front sous les coups là je m'éclate
contre le mur et je tombe par terre dans
la foule et je suis resté environ deux
minutes par terre aucun être humain qui
s'est arrêté et ça je vous garantis que
ça m'a marqué pendant un bon bout mais
toute sa vie on est tenté de le dire et
sans doute à l'image de cette petite
phrase celle d'un homme d'honneur
intègre et sensible puisque celle d'un
grand comédien lino ventura sera demain
soir sur antenne 2 à 22h25
hasard de l'actualité le monde de la
voile lui aussi en état de choc
aujourd'hui daniel gilard a disparu en
mer alors qu'il disputait la course
la baule dakar vous connaissiez bien
daniel gilard nous connaissions bien
jeune daniel gilard nous tous les gens
habitués à voir la voile
malheureusement dany girard a disparu il
est tombé à l'eau et nous je vous
propose d'écouter pour l'instant son
dernier témoignage génère communications
de téléphonie que nous avons ainsi que
celle de son coéquipier lorsqu'il s'est
rendu compte de la disparition de neige
il c'était ce matin c'est
ce matin malheureusement la chance de
lui a pas souri deux heures après il
disparaît en mer écoutons son coéquipier
à 20 navires
oui j'en sais le problème de la sécurité
qui est une nouvelle fois posé ses
formules 1 de la mer vont vraiment trop
vite que qu'est-ce qui se passe que
faudrait il faire il n'avait pas son
harnais est sans doute la lorraine là le
problème est de savoir s'il faut
s'attacher ou non dans des conditions
comme celles qu'on rencontrait le
navigateur aujourd'hui c'est à dire 40 à
45 noeuds de vent à peu près 80 90 km
heure par une mère qui représente à peu
près 3 4 5 mètres de creux et c'est très
dangereux
donc le moine la moindre vague le
moindre faux mouvement vous entraîne à
l'eau ça a été le cas
halvard mabire son coéquipier a essayé
de faire demi-tour il a lancé un bip ce
qu'on appelle c'est à dire un secours
premier pour essayer de repérer son
équipier le temps qu'il revienne et
qu'il manoeuvre tout seul ce grand
bateau il est revenu il a aperçu à la
fois le bip et halvard mabire et daniel
gilard malheureusement lorsqu'il est
passé une deuxième fois
dany girard a disparu mais le bip est
toujours là et depuis il tourne sur zone
il ya un avion qui est partie pour être
tenté de repérer des dealers mais au fil
des heures le l'espoir s'amenuise de les
retrouver vivants lorsqu'on est habillé
avec un ciré chaudement par des mers
froides
il est très difficile de survivre et je
crois que la mère a donné rendez-vous à
dainville à un moment il ne tournait pas
voyons rapidement les autres faits
marquants de l'actualité en commençant
par l'instabilité des marchés financiers
les bourses européennes et asiatiques
ont plutôt mal réagi aux propos de
ronald reagan
hier soir le président des états unis
s'est engagé à réduire le déficit
budgétaire américain tout en laissant
entendre qu'il pourrait augmenter les
impôts
apparemment ça n'a pas suffi alain
douguet ski tokyo c'est l'effondrement
la bourse a connu une nouvelle forte
baisse qui efface cette fois
définitivement la hausse record de mardi
dernier
paris la journée s'est achevée sur une
baisse de 0 46% selon l'indicateur
instantanée depuis le début d'année
la baisse est ainsi de 14% francfort les
cours des actions reculé de 2 4% en
moyenne
l'indicé la commerzbank a terminé au
dessous du bas niveau atteint mardi
dernier londres les valeurs ont réduit
leurs pertes en fin de séance
un coup de frein aux baisses dues à
l'annoncé surprise de la réduction des
taux de base bancaire britannique
au lendemain du discours de ronald
reagan où on attendait avec impatience
la réaction de la bourse de new york
wall street est plus que jamais vous le
savez le baromètre avec lequel il faut
compter
bref une nouvelle chute de wall street
signifierait à coup sûr une perte de
confiance dans la personne du président
reagan à new york
commentaire de paul nahon wall street a
mal réagi aux propos du président des
états unis grand jour devant la bourse
de new york où des milliers de touristes
américains étaient venus assister à la
séance
toutes les télévisions et mettait en
direct et le dow jones à l'ouverture
avait perdu une trentaine de points à
l'évidence ronald regan a pas convaincu
et le président de la plus grande firme
de courtage du monde nous l'a confirmé
le président a fait un discours trop
partisan mais il a quand même fait des
progrès en affirmant qu'il était prêt à
envisager d'augmenter les impôts c'est
ce qui attendait beaucoup de gens c'est
ce qu'attendait wall street
mais tout cela n'est pas allée très loin
c'est lundi que le président américain
devrait rencontrer les membres du
congrès pour tenter de trouver une
solution à l'énorme déficit du budget
pour certains experts la maison blanche
n'a pas encore pris la mesure de la
crise voilà la semaine est terminée
alors à et et harassante est terrible
pour les boursiers de wall street mais
aussi et surtout pour l'économie
américaine
alors maintenant comme des millions
d'hommes d'affaires et de petits
porteurs aux états unis je vais composer
un numéro pour avoir automatiquement les
derniers cours de wall street
quelques minutes avant sa fermeture le
976 41 41
alors deux informations importantes le
dollar est en chute par rapport au mark
allemand
le dow jones lui récupère 13 points par
rapport à la séance d'hier et terminent
aux environs de 1936 merci paul en
france une réaction intéressante celle
d'edmond maire monsieur maire demande à
son tour une pause dans les
privatisations
et clark la crise financière si elles
s'amplifier pourrait avoir de graves
répercussions sociales écoutez le les
désordres monétaires on a regardé ça de
près et là nous sommes maintenant hélas
persuadé que cela va conduire à un
ralentissement de l'économie a donc à
une augmentation du chômage et à une
remontée de l'inflation s'il ya des
conséquences sociales extrêmement grave
alors nous demandons au gouvernement de
faire preuve de sagesse
même si ce gouvernement et cette
majorité une option pour la
privatisation l'intérêt national
commande aujourd'hui d'arrêter des
privatisations de ne pas aggraver les
phénomènes et il faut en même temps que
les gouvernements s'entendent entre eux
c'est vraiment l'intérêt social de ce
pays
voilà c'était cet après midi au cours
d'une conférence de presse avec pascal
vanier voyons maintenant les télex de
l'étranger
un soldat à l'entraînement ce dauphin
appartient à une unité spéciale de la
marine américaine sa mission détecter
les mines iranienne du gol ici on
commando l'intelligence du dauphin fait
la différence
il doit repérer les charges sans les
toucher une guerre sous-marine plutôt
inattendue la haute technologie
américaines intéresse les soviétiques
illégalement si le aux trois personnes
dont deux français ont été arrêtés en
californie il s'apprêtait à vendre à
lurs les plans d'un ordinateur
stratégique pour la fameuse guerre des
étoiles à la demande du chef de l'
agence spatiale soviétique oréfice déjà
avoué la chute d'une cravache d'or
lester piggott condamné à trois ans de
prison ferme par le tribunal d'ipswitch
l'autre talent du jockey anglais la
fraude des gains placés dans différentes
banques et sous des noms d'emprunt 3
millions de livres 30 millions de francs
dissimulé au fisc depuis une dizaine
d'années
regardez su visage fatigué george
schultz n'a pas n'a pu annoncer qu'un
accord virtuel sur l'élimination totale
des missiles l'intermédiaire américain
des soviétiques bloque encore sur les
détails de la vérification
toujours pas de date pour le sommet
reggane gorbatchev le numéro un
soviétique n'est pas encore tout à fait
prêt a déclaré george shultz au burkina
faso la vie reprend son cours quelques
jours après le coup d'état qui a porté
au pouvoir le capitaine compaoré le
nouvel homme fort qui tente de s'imposer
depuis quelques temps accordé sa
première interview à notre envoyé
spécial martin laroche joubert
monsieur compaoré évoque l' enterrement
à la sauvette du président sankara et
l'avenir immédiat du pays
écoutez le nous pensons que c'est un
devoir pour nous darrin jeu sera tendre
de respecter sa mémoire vous avez des
regrets d'avoir perdu un ami bien sûr et
un regret aussi carrément de sa vie il
est pensé à nous liquidez dommage
vous
pendant que ce qui est important pour
nous ce qui a été un acquis pour les
révolutionnaires c'était bien sûr
l'engagement massif des populations
autour de mon ordre au départ et ça il
faut qu'on arrive à revenir sur cette
situation
avant d'engager je crois que ce soit et
c'est sûr que nous allons emprunter ce
que nous allons essayer de tenter de
réaliser retour en france le
gouvernement propose un plan de lutte
contre la pauvreté le plan a été
divulgué aujourd'hui à l'issue du
conseil des ministres
concrètement 470 millions de francs ont
été dégagés afin de faire en sorte que
personne cet hiver ne soit démunie de
logements et de ressources
ce plan suffira t-il à gommer la
réflexion que nous allons entendre tout
le monde le souhaite
agnès poirier seul et sans ressources
l'homme était couché sur le trottoir une
commerçante appelle alors un médecin cet
homme qui a été maçon il ya longtemps
mais qui survit dans la rue depuis 10
ans n'a pas pu se faire accepter à
l'hôpital
prévue avec l'hiver cet homme va pouvoir
bénéficier des actions d'urgence mis en
place par le gouvernement
hébergement et nourriture grâce au
surplus européen pour les sans abri ils
sont 200 milles en france désormais une
autre possibilité
on échange d'une activité est revenu
minimum de 2000 francs et une couverture
sociale c'est la généralisation du
système dit des compléments locaux de
ressources qui permettent de donner deux
mille francs par mois de revenus plus
une protection sociale ce qui est très
important évidemment à des personnes
démunies de toute ressource qui
acceptent un travail une activité
d'intérêt général ou une formation qui
leur est proposé localement par une
collectivité locale un hôpital maison de
retraite tous telle manière que cette
personne est non seulement une sécurité
mais aussi à nouveau un rôle dans la
société et 78 départements vont
appliquer cette nouvelle mesure du
gouvernement vient de débloquer 470
millions de francs pour lutter contre la
précarité et la pauvreté
ce matin le conseil des ministres a
également adopté des mesures
exceptionnelles en faveur de quatre
départements bretons et deux
départements normands durement éprouvées
récemment par la tempête
l'état de catastrophe entre guillemets
catastrophe naturelle a été constatée
pour les côtes-du-nord l'ille-et-vilaine
le finistère le morbihan la manche et le
calvados
indépendamment des aides qui vont
intervenir dans les semaines qui
viennent
certains agriculteurs ont déjà fait
jouer les assurances pour limiter les
dégâts bien sûr en quête de patrice
volée pour une bonne expertise
il faut un entrepreneur un assureur et
un expert bien sûr l'objet de toutes
leurs attentions ce matin la porcherie
de roland buc un de gros dégâts
plusieurs toitures endommagées et dans
son contrat d'assurance une garantie
tempête
le travail de l'expert évaluer le
préjudice au mieux des intérêts parfois
contradictoires de l'exploitant et de
son assureur discussions techniques avec
l'artisan chargé de la reconstruction
les deux hommes s'accordent sur les
réparations indispensables choisissent
les matériaux en bretagne près d'une
exploitation sur deux a reçu ou recevra
une visite d'un expert
l'urgence est partout des dizaines de
vies
deux dossiers sont en attente dans un
premier temps nous avons bien évidemment
rencontrer le maximum de nos assurés et
ensuite au fur et à mesure qu'elles ont
vu leurs entreprises leurs artisans
nous les voyons pour envisager leur
règlement donc vous rencontrez des gens
pour conclure des dossiers en ce moment
absolument là actuellement nous
commençons à revoir les premiers qu'ils
ont fourni leurs devis et avec des
entrepreneurs
nous concluons d accord et nous payons
nos assurés
l'heure des comptes la dernière étape de
l' expertise accord à l'amiable entre
les parties
compte tenu d'une franchise de onze
mille francs roland buc 1 a touché ce
matin 80 9368 francs de quoi
reconstruire ses bâtiments et relancer
son élevage de porcs dans quelques mois
il aura droit à une autre indemnité
elle servira à compenser ces pertes
d'exploitation je donne rapidement je
suppose que vous les attendez les
pronostics de pierres et de noyade
obtient être bresse pour le tiercé de
demain qui se courra sur l'hippodrome
d'auteuil
16 partants pirette vous conseille de
jouer le 12 et le street le 15/10
accountant le un coaster green le 5
richelieu-drouot ça c'est plus facile à
lire le set carson city le 8 imams du
tenue le 3 game boy le 2 litres fait
seize n'ont pas cessé le nombre de
partants 12 15 1 5 7 8 3 et de la météo
du week-end josé je crois qu'il ya pas
de miracle a malheureusement et non et
non reid maintiennent le masquer par le
nuage bien entendu ce n'est pas la photo
satellite qui me contredira en effet des
nuages nous quitte par le nord-est et
d'autres arrivent par le sud ouest
voici les images je l'espère ans sinon
voici donc les nuages nous quitte
d'autres arrivent par le sud-ouest ils
vont envahir vous le verrez sur tout le
sud du pays résultat pour demain le ciel
sera surtout couvert il y aura de la
pluie sur le languedoc-roussillon la
vallée du rhône et le nord des alpes
le midi et la côte d'azur ne seront pas
épargnés les pyrénées le centre du pays
jusqu'au bassin parisien
or on a eu des nuages mais quelques
rayons de soleil mais vraiment très très
timide
en revanche regarder sur la bretagne la
normandie nouvelles sont bonnes il y
aura demain du soleil côté température
et bien c'est la baisse nous sommes en
deçà des normes saisonnières vous allez
voir le long des côtes de la manche 11 2
ray pas davantage trait à paris et dans
le sud nous aurons un agréable 22 encore
et demain samedi 24 octobre ce sera la
saint florentin instinct que l'on évoque
pour lutter contre la mélancolie et
c'est d'actualité
tout à fait prochain rendez vous
d'information 22h55 le journal sera
présentée par au brier de l'air qui est
de retour pendant le week-end vous
retrouverez daniel bilalian et philippe
gassot et comme tous les samedis bernard
rapp sera fidèle au poste à 13h15 pour
l'assiette anglaise
bon week end et à lundi soir